by December of 2015 the dollar fluid
made its way into Washington DC and a
hit hard within days the once bustling
suburban areas of the US Capitol turned
into a derelict and dangerous urban
jungle for most people looting became a
requirement to survival with shops and
pharmacies being the main targets those
who were prepared with supplies locked
themselves in their homes and tried to
hold off until help arrived some DC
communities made more communal efforts
people banded together in settlements
built fortified walls and shared
resources and supplies in the early days
of the DC outbreak many settlements
started to pop up including Sarah create
refugee camps for tourists but became an
unofficial network of barter and shared
security however by February with the
rise of organized gangs and other
hostile factions raiding and carving out
territories in the city they quickly
began to pull apart the smaller
settlements eventually only three of the
largest settlements remained the castle
the campus and the theater
[Music]
[Music]
after the original smallpox outbreak in
December Sara established one of his
very first refugee camps in the
Smithsonian castle in the National Mall
this camp housed out-of-towners who are
stranded in southern DC over time the
castle was transformed into DC's very
first settlement as it contained ample
resources medical services and had an
organized and effective defense system
in place despite heavy rioting and
looting to the north the castle remained
a safe and secure shelter for its
occupants however as winter turned into
spring attacks on the settlement grew
more frequent and a new faction of ex
jtf called the true sons moved into the
area and expanded west towards more by
April the castle was essentially
surrounded by the true son's territory
and was completely cut off from the JTF
base of operations in the White House
the true sons allowed the castle to
exist if they continued to supply the
resources to the troops but in June
negotiations fell through and the true
sons launched a DC 62 chemical attack on
the castle cinnamoned killing most of
its residents in a matter of minutes to
this day the settlement remains
uninhabitable due to the toxic chemical
residue that has been left behind
in December Sara established a refugee
center in the large open field on the
campus of the George Washington
University just west of the White House
for more than a month the camp focused
on providing patient treatment housing
tourists trapped in the city and keeping
the social unrest to a minimum
but as winter dragged on refugee camps
around the city began to fall over on
small pop cases and armed thugs raiding
their supplies Sara began pulling health
care workers out of the more dangerous
camps by february the university camp
now called the campus was the only
functioning refugee center that remained
recognizing that both sarah and the JTF
was stretched by the pandemic and we're
considering total withdrawal from the
field campus citizens began to take
steps in order to become self-sufficient
and a long-term sustaining community
firstly they built defenses to use
against hyena readers who are
continuously raiding the camp next using
the green spaces around the campus
they've gone to plant and cultivate food
crops finally the residents elected a
leader named Henry Hayes to oversee the
restructuring of the camp into a
fortified and self-sustaining settlement
Hayes is organized and methodical and
excelled at keeping the camp operational
and secure however when it came to the
happiness of the people under his
leadership he struggled to see its
importance under his direction sacrifice
was expected from all and personally
sure was viewed as unnecessary and even
with hostility the settlement was a
thriving that cheerless place with every
waking moment devoted to procuring food
and water and maintaining the shelter
and security life settled into a hive
lack routine work and sleep anything
that distracted the settlers from his
goal was deemed as unacceptable this
lead to resentment within the community
outside influences started to infiltrate
the camp infections such as the outcasts
and their ideas studied become more and
more attractive to the residents the
month of April brought some relief from
the cold weather but also a new threat
from the West
Raiders calling themselves the outcasts
began a series of hit and run strikes on
the settlement and started harassing
campus foraging teams who are venturing
out of the camp look at the supplies but
far worse the outcast philosophy was
becoming popular and alluring to the
residents within the camp and a number
of prominent residents became converts
one of which was Henry Hayes own wife
who eventually lived the campus and
joined the outcasts after this
Trustin Hayes leadership came under
scrutiny from the residents and he was
asked to stick down however he refused
to do so a lonely bird himself deeper
into his methods of running the compound
listen turn further promoting more
people to leave the settlement and join
the outcasts and by June the outcasts
have gained full control of the area and
it completely surrounded the campus
[Music]
the last major settlement in DC to
survive the growing hostile presence was
established in ford's theatre the
theatre began filling up and March
citizens in the area sought refuge from
the increasing gang attacks from the
hyena faction the settlements leader is
former division agent Odessa soyah soyah
was born and raised in DC so she has a
good sense of local awareness she is a
tough operative and field commander who
is a prosthetic leg after being wounded
in combat during her sh deactivation of
DC saw his husband was murdered shortly
after she began active duty and as a
result she struggles with dark impulses
including severe anger and PTSD
the theater had a difficult start as it
was built during constant attacks from
the hyenas and with multiple security
threats and other setbacks this affected
and continues to affect its people's
morale
although the settlement is well
organized under soyuz command there's
still a feeling of anger and dread by
everyone within the encampment settlers
are exhausted and a suffering from a
growing sense of hopelessness only made
worse by the growing high inner presence
around the camp residents have selected
a corps council headed by Sawyer to keep
things running but there is a severe
lack of community problems like graffiti
vandalism theft and even substance abuse
continues to be a complication
although protected for now and habitants
are isolated and access to outside
resources is only getting more difficult
as time goes on thanks for watching
before I go I really need to do the
stereotypical call-out of my social
media in hopes that they'll start to
grow and people will stop making fun of
me for help etheric and irrelevant they
are check out the description from my
Twitter discord to Instagram and a bunch
of other things that apparently I'm
supposed to have yeah Cheers
[Music]
[Music]